e oggi premura nuova challenge e cioè lo
slime in ordine alfabetico come funziona
e la challenge che è stata fatta già da
un canale americano sisters rho in cui
fanno lo slime in ordine alfabetico
quindi tutti gli ingredienti con la
prima poi di poesia eccetera eccetera
cosa abbiano deciso di palla con la
ruota quindi c'è tutto l'alfabeto nella
muta e come funziona noi ci teniamo la
moda qualsiasi lettera ci capiterà
dobbiamo trovare un ingrediente iniziale
con quella lettera se entro 30 secondi
non riusciamo a trovare niente con
quello iniziare con quella lettera
l'altra persona potrà decidere
l'ingrediente sempre con quella lettera
è complicatissimo anche l'altra persona
non riesce a trovare niente con cui
l'iniziale allora volta il turno e non
si potrà mettere su niente super
divertente ne vedremo delle belle
siamo come cattivi ma allora come sempre
alla fine il video vi metterò questo
modo potrete votare se dico io o sevizie
vitale in base
anche se tu stai questo arriviamo
simpatia di evitare questi tiri comodi
prende tipo come i timori
vediamo chi distingue perché per ogni
mio passo e 60 vediamo anche con la
nuova ruota gira veloce meno scegliere
di 30 secondi dal m.llo colombe dirlo
dai vip è qua c'è scritto cosa c'è
scritto il vestito viola lo resti non
troppo invece non solo quelli sul tavolo
è quello che cosa ti viene in mente del
morire dai club è giusto è giusto fare a
meno di burana partendo dalla barella
signori
ma corrente e quindi decido io e io ho
deciso il colore barra care di crearlo
io con questi colori allora per fare in
marrone mette un po di arancione è
capito che funzionava così si è visto
non colore marrone color inventato da te
deve essere un vero colore quindi in
questo caso marrone mette un po di
arancione è un po di nero perché un bel
marrone o lo domandiamo visti anno prima
giro io
[Applauso]
p p
allora aspetti
[Musica]
posso anche se glieli colore che mi pare
gialloblù palline ma lancetta mete le
palline viva sarebbe un bel grazie a
matri stage ottavo marrone dai vi stiamo
vediamo se uscito per un errore clicca
il nero è schizzato di la s marrone di
rho
beh se sei fortunato ti esce arancione
invece che marrone perché con bellissimi
divenuto marrone un burrone chiaro ha
messo poco di nero perde per 3 0 2
venuto niente in mete con la m
avere un argomento in mente deve essere
rapido in questa challenge invece il mio
slime è bellissimo perché è già francica
per le palline
speriamo solo di non rovinarlo con altri
ingredienti 300 litri o di ora fisso
scendere questa volta si è salvato
perchè ripeto d'orchestra è un vero
colore turchese pure scritto turchese
dei temi tecnici per aver letto la
gestiremo un po accame packa ah ah ah ah
ah le utility con like mi vengano tutte
parole inglese hotel in utero mattino ti
suggerisco perché ci sono con casco
giacca o chiaro un ingrediente italiano
sentiamo anche loro la soluzione
barletti acqua all'ora come l'acqua
di questo barbaro così controllo di
ciclist allo slide be the place like
grazie cose che sono cose punto che
vediamo un po come diventa il tuo un bar
renzino per il turchese colore brutta
cosa fare e mettere così tante belle
bardolino addio un po water agi cli
poveri non mi sembra ho paura di quel
vero che è rimasto league
no devo stare attento a non prenderlo
perché se dovesse un colorato italpatate
titolare marrone perché sono previsioni
del remo cos'altro ps adesso quando si
ha un pò scicli spero che si attivi dopo
ecco qua oddio è un passo troppo
spero dopo seriosi relativa all uscirà
un cd craxi non mai fatto uno slime gig
con le palline
oddio mi schiavo mi schiavo che strano
primo separato prima dopo dovrebbe
attivarsi lo stesso sarà gisley e tranci
grazie per avermi fatto questo favore ed
estendo nuovo a questa ruota di roma
[Applauso]
ma a ruba natia telephone essere 9 di
colori come truman oggetti fa per me sto
cercando di perché questo sotto la
regola o anche voi i commenti potete
scrivere tutte le cose con le lettere
nel frattempo ricordo per l'uso di ogni
giorno sei fortunato che ce l'abbiamo
l'unicorno altrimenti sarebbe toccato a
me aspettiamo alla fine come decorazione
attacca a me vediamo viene o dio
no no no d'altro canto valente
[Musica]
nebulizzatore estradata sinopoli
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ma si sa che qui facendo io siamo poco
poco non per farlo diventare nero che
tutto uniforme giorno caduti dopo poco
si esce con il rigetto capitale
prendiamo problema ci guarda strane ccs
solo con in mente per farmi vedere se le
trovo anche un altro f di fds con
salmone ad ora ci sono le strutture vero
anno riuniamo celeste cv celeste a
questa veste di celeste
[Applauso]
sei fortunato anche questa volta ci
siamo un po come con il tutto va bene
dice liste ci sono pure ci sono pure le
paillettes o le paillettes non si
chiamano i brillantini addio entra un
bellissimo verde acqua e quasi non si
vede però si vedono i brillantini
[Musica]
berlino come dr li noviziato ora dorme
nel letto ecco qua il nero che mi ha
messo evitare maledetto vediamo un po
come diventano grigio red è che crescono
è neanche chiaro perline tutta calorico
un bel colore abete guarda però le
palline sul nero e di come si vedono di
più che alves è su di tcs più sudditi
secondo me è suddetti infatti vedi che
indica proprio alle fatti cdt dinamite
dovuto ad perché magari batteria che
parla di aspetta o cosa ti dolorante 8
per 6 0
perché al conflitto proprio il brutto in
mezzo a un altra cosa ma fa sentire
durante la rovina per il trio oppure
3 trasporti tavolo perché poi scelgo io
dove torna in mente qualcosa tutto
normali ecco ce l'avete il proprio
vicino al 3 si è accorta questi si
friggono milanesi hanno infatti mai non
si tira mai
noi siamo un popolo oppure abbiamo già
dato
berlino ha chiesto a villa dov'era che
sta verificando lasciatemi dormire
dentifricio me la spiga b totale questo
challenge luigino mai recupero secoli
del centrodestra vero che ci sarà
terribile
mi è venuta in mente una cosa o come
stati l'olio nello slime hanno però
purtroppo temo che metterò valore
ombretti ho potuto bruschetta non non è
rosea
ecco qua il dentifricio probabilmente
questo sly non si arriverà mai perché il
dentifricio distruggerà colla nell'isla
quindi forte non si attiverà vaio spero
che si attiverà lo stesso perché
altrimenti perderò di sicuro i rom lo
slime sarotto sfortunato sociale ma
guarda che carino il tuo slide di
marchetti ci fai qui ferisca ecco qua il
signorino fortunato sta mettendo loro
nel suo zaino diamo loro ora che fortuna
epidemia ottimo mettete marrone come
direttore lo monaco tutto questo verde
che c'è
a marrone ma 9 ma non è che il prossimo
turno il vizio
tu hai tirato quindi tocca quasi i
credenti in colore bianco o nero col
colore come salvatore l'ultimo è tutto
per carità e qualche colore turchese
libero porta prenderà un colore più
carino vediamo come ora dubbi ora lo
copiano 26 mar diventarono uguali o
forse no toccate gmn quello che è
capitato prima a me ma non mi ricordo
che cosa abbiamo deciso
mmm ti puoi salvare solo se ti viene in
mente qualcos'altro
cassetti minimamente cosa è messa come
collega qualche non estro in colore nero
[Applauso]
tumori live non meno non meno non è
ripetuto nero nero nero toccarelli tempo
nastro un altro nastro ci metto il
nastro all'interno della slide battaglia
tutto a pezzettini per il caso ti sei
salvato per questa volta tagliamo il
nastro ramona si tratta si strato su
strato portierato far divenire in mente
questa cosa
sono fortunato con intelligente anche se
secondo me non si starà bene così come
lo è ogni altro fatto a coriandoli
centro lo slide che tra l'altro pure con
lavoro nastro oro giallo male giallo e
oro lo impreziosisce ancora di più come
se la mettiamo proprio tale allora ecco
qua qua sera il nero sindaco indaco
dagli occhi dal cielo vediamo se
cambierà colore è il mio colore
preferito st diretta a dover di allora
vai salva la maledizione del verde
decisamente copiato dal mio va il mio
più bello mai ne hanno copiato proprio
un bel finale il mio vero che ora mi
capiterà un super coro magari blu così
il posto rendon allora un ultimo turno
attenzione perché questo deciderà le
sorti del nostro turismo voglio
assolutamente migliorare il tuo porta
riporta una nota che sono prenotato bene
l'ultimo immaginato troppo cose come
evitare magari ora non lo farà perché
questa è una nuova ruota quindi ancora
non ci conosce bene per sfiga bene
invece che abita le sorridiamo
neanche ci metti adesso l'unica cosa
cosa che quello che ha detto e cioè
l'acqua
ap la marca o no lo rendo gb e il colore
rimarrà sempre rendo che tu hai in mente
qualcos'altro con l'acca no di sudore
che devo dire i nostri dati viene in
mente dal mio non mettere sostenuto lo
metterà altro a caso era veramente le
sedi dove si sta strutturando si mette
niente
quindi io metto l'acqua toccate attento
che questo destino di rpr il 20 le cose
anche due è lei allora mi è venuta ieri
di rosso però il rosso con questa
diretta marrone quindi se gioca un po di
bianco bianco bianco bianco e di cura
sono sicuro al momento interrotta ma si
diventa la lattuga
non mi piacciono da questo bianco
attraverso te l'abbiamo
ecco perché devi mettere cavolo di
bianco non cambia di al teatro slavi
viagra filo che ritrasmettono il rosso
poi dopo mi dimentico ma ora mi è
proprio per togliere a meglio metterlo
poca cosa bianca immagine con l'ambiente
fatto nuovo vediamo un po come che
chiarisse secondo me diventerà un host
line di un colore bellissimo no rimane
sempre così perché ne ho messo poco si è
schiarito poco i piani di male ma
rimetto ha proposto il bel david
prescritto e robot è calcolato
aggiungere l'acqua in realtà non so
ancora se slide si attiverà perché c'è
il editrice o dentro aggiungo un po
darmi un po giusto un po magari diventa
tigri e furono denaro per lui perché si
dovrebbe più attivare dei claim cos'è
quel fango fango di camion di riuscire
ad attivarlo poverty paper b il colore è
questo fango e gavio e ora andiamo alla
si va nello studio se riesco ad
attivarlo altrimenti vi darò uno che fa
notizia
speriamo che vinse prodi
ecco qua il mio sly quest'anno riuscita
ad attivarlo è viva
allora è un po di glee vedete è un po di
lì per l'acqua
poi è anche un po sì perché un politico
l'unica cosa che non mi piace per niente
ovviamente il colore perché aperto e
quindi la maledizione del verde sempre
presente 20 a un po di suoni fmr
[Applauso]
che sono state soprattutto le molle
molto rilassante peccato per il colore
di amore a quella di evitare che si
completi live tour che è bellissimo non
so se si vedono il pochettino ci sono
più che altro si sentono nelle mani
quando ci si gioca nello stupendo re
davvero davvero bellissimo altro punto
verde petrolio tante bollicine e ci sono
tutti i pezzettini di mestrino color oro
non so se vedete davvero bello mi piace
un fatto questo sliven ho attivato
abbastanza decentemente e niente fa un
sacco di rumori e mi piace un sacco e
bellissimo che emettiamo di uno a fianco
all'altro questi voi potete decidere di
sentire il suo cappello per ora tutto
non mobilitazione di tutti i mezzi di
berlino prima testata avevo dimenticato
non ultimo ingrediente io ero mettere
mai il turchese e quindi votate qua ti
dice se vinco io ho te vince vitale
votate consigliate si nei commenti che
altre challenge slime pare e ora vi
lasciamo quindi care cliccate su quella
che ha preferito e bora miglia intorno